can we can we talk about the logic
lines yeah yeah let's do it um i've
known logic for a very long time
uh i don't
take him as a culture vulture no
obviously i'm a white man in hip-hop
so you know you could yeah think what
you want about that yeah um
but you know i kind of have known
dude since about 2013 and you know i
know him as like a
hardcore hip-hop fan like that's how me
and him connected was through
conversations about like equipment
you know just just a lot of rap [ __ ]
yeah um
he seems like i mean he's a very
disliked guy the last
five or six years but but what what is
um what what's the issue with logic and
why did he get that those bars for me
it's funny because that's the
misunderstanding of the line and i
learned a good lesson on that i learned
two lessons timing
uh as far as reading the room and also
like if you're going to say something
you you need to
kind of go in a little bit more detail
when i rap i just kind of
rap about what i'm feeling at the time
so uh i
too have loved logic since like like
damn near 2010
and um kind of going off what we said
earlier like if i'm a fan of you i hold
you accountable
a lot of fans thought that i was saying
he's a culture vulture of hip-hop
that's not what i was talking about you
know what i'm saying and so
um from a hip-hop standpoint you can't
talk about the last 10 years of hip-hop
without talking about logic like he's
he's in that category you know he's not
as big as kendrick and them but he's in
that category
yeah some respect on his name yeah
so what i was speaking about was the
fact that logic is a black man
and uh logic is uh somebody that has
talked about black plight black struggle
that's what he talked about on his come
up and then when he got to a certain
album
um i think it was everybody and he
touched on a lot of issues that was
going on in america suicide transgenders
gays everybody
and i personally felt like he didn't
touch on black lives matter enough
so when i said the line about the
culture i just meant
black culture is what got you to the
point that you're at so when you're at
the top of your platform where now
you're ready
to explode to the world to have this
huge artist like
talk about us too and that's what i
meant by that
and um that just comes from my passion
for black
culture in general and black lives and
what's going on with black people and
stuff like that
i mean it came from that perspective you
know what i'm saying they had nothing to
do with hip-hop had nothing to do with
records or rapping and nothing like that
like i'm a logic fan but like i said
earlier like i
i hold people accountable i would never
want somebody i would want somebody to
do the same thing with me if i get to a
certain
platform and now i'm about to have that
album that explodes it's like you still
gotta
remember why you're doing this which is
to you know bring awareness you know
what i mean to people and stuff like
that yeah i think
i actually was not a fan of that album
that's probably uh and now
exactly i think a lot of people that
were hardcore logic fans weren't yeah
yeah
honestly like this last album that just
dropped is incredible was the last album
like the first album i've [ __ ] with
since his second album the
incredible journey or just true story
one yeah
no pressure is incredible no pressure's
fire but yeah i think that like i don't
know man i just think that
you know i think that's a fair criticism
um you know i think that album everybody
was like
i think he was dealing with a lot of the
biracial [ __ ] he's probably meant to be
yeah i think that he was just probably
having a lot of
people don't know logic is black yeah no
thousands what did you say i think he
was probably having a lot of meetings
and stuff like that you know i mean i
don't want to
speculate too much but i think that
people are telling them like this is
what you have to do to get to the next
to the next level you know what i mean
and that's my my whole thing is you know
i'm just
if i'm a fan of you you know what i mean
i'm going to i'm like i said i'm one of
the more honest artists in this [ __ ] i
don't
i don't necessarily i don't have the
goals like everybody else has to be the
the greatest of all time because i don't
believe that exists like in 10 years
there's going to be somebody that's
going to tell you
nba young boy is better than kendrick
it's going to happen like so
listen there is
exactly so for me it's like i just want
to make impact and i want to
i want to broker honest conversations
and try to make an impact to where
people
you know elevate their their honesty
their accountability their
responsibility whatever the case may be
and so but like i said i'm not going to
escape my accountability in it
i didn't read the room you know logic
when i wrote it he wasn't retired he's
retired now he's trying to do his own
thing you know what i mean and so that
is something that
if i could go back i wouldn't i just
wouldn't say the line out there because
it's like
let him do his thing you know what i
mean and so it would be a conversation
that if i ever met him i would have with
him personally still
but um um i wouldn't necessarily put it
out for the record i don't think there's
a chance in hell he doesn't know who you
are like he said oh no he definitely
knows
but i like i like the it's like bro
you're you're a hip-hop stan
and this is top dog entertainment yeah
you know and he's a kendrick stan
exactly exactly yeah but he is shout out
to logic though like his career
musically like
i'd be lucky if i was able to reach that
level
i'm glad you made that clear because
like like you know a lot of people took
it from a hip-hop standpoint which i
can't blame them and it's funny because
when it dropped i'm like
oh damn it does sound like i'm saying
that like it does sound like yeah
because i was thinking like you know
like yeah i know logic is like a real
hip-hop head like this guy you know he
works with no ideas
you know you can't you can't and that's
what i'm saying like you can't say logic
isn't
a hip-hop guy and that's not what i was
saying but you know
i understand why i understand why you
said that though